[Música]
llegó la hora de la información
económica en france 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero luís
mente es luís bienvenido comenzamos
hablando del proceso de sindicalización
de los centros de distribución de amazon
en eeuu que ocurrió con la votación
llevada a cabo el día de hoy
lamentablemente los trabajadores se
llevaron un revés en esta propuesta de
llevar a cabo un sindicato luego de que
un centro de distribución ubicado en la
ciudad de nueva york consiguiera a
principios del mes de abril la
conformación y la aceptación del mismo
de acuerdo con medios estadounidense en
la votación se cerró con 618 votos o un
63 por ciento del electorado que se
espesó en contra de la conformación de
la agrupación de trabajadores para
aquellos que defienden el derecho a
agruparse en un sindicato manifestaron
que prácticas ilegales de la compañía
podrían haber influido en los resultados
y bueno desafortunadamente se completó
el recuento de votos y el sindicato de
trabajadores de amazon no obtuvo la
mayoría creo que fué 618 380 lo cual es
un resultado decepcionante
amazon dio un paso al frente hubo mucha
presión en las últimas dos semanas donde
se involucraron en muchos
comportamientos ilegales
disciplinaron a los organizadores
disciplinaron a otros trabajadores por
participar en actividades coercitivas y
realmente lo hicieron lo más difícil
posible espacio
la asociación que promueve la
sindicalización dentro de esta compañía
se pronunció respecto al resultado
reconociendo los resultados del mismo y
además indicando que la lucha apenas
comienza
porque louis se inició toda esta carrera
para agrupar a los trabajadores de
amazon en un sindicato
valentín esto tiene su origen cuando
empezó la pandemia de kobe 19 y en la
que muchos trabajadores de los centros
de distribución en gran parte del mundo
denunciaron condiciones de inseguridad
para los empleados debido a toda la
situación sanitaria entre ellos chris
moyles quien protestó por esa situación
y se convirtió en la cara visible de los
sindicatos de amazon a lo largo y ancho
de todo eeuu que buscan entre otras
cosas mayores beneficios para los
empleadores parte de sus empleadores
evitar que estos dependen en mayor
medida del gobierno que buscan los
trabajadores con el sindicato entre los
beneficios están plantear negociaciones
de contratos colectivos es decir
beneficios por igual para todos los
trabajadores y que quede por escrito
condiciones de trabajo más justas y
también cambiar el estatus de trabajador
a voluntad por un trabajador a causa
justa' lo que implica que para ser
despedido debe existir una justificación
pero pasamos ahora a europa porque sigue
el debate en torno a un embargo total a
las importaciones de gas y petróleo ruso
por parte de la unión europea hoy hubo
reunión y un debate que se mantiene
porque todavía no está un consenso
unánime para tomar la medida debido a la
dependencia de gas y petróleo ruso en
varias naciones de acuerdo con informes
de la unión europea la dependencia de
este bloque de 27
a la caza y al petróleo es decir está en
un 26% por el petróleo el 40% para el
gas pero no existen o en este caso
existen naciones como hungría y
eslovaquia donde están oponiéndose a un
embargo total porque la dependencia está
por encima del 90% pero en el encuentro
de este lunes y del que se esperan
resultados para este martes sería un
giro importante pues alemania que es un
importante importador de productos
energéticos rusos ha mostrado una
disposición al embargo contrario a lo
que presentaba meses atrás aunque se
están preparando para lo que podría
venir en caso de no conseguir más
suministro energético por parte de rusia
para ello la importación de gas se
redujo de un 55 a un 35 por ciento
previo a lo que fue la invasión de rusia
ucrania pero temen que un bloqueo total
en los próximos meses afecten la
economía tal como lo ha advertido el
bundesbank que prevé una caída por
encima del 5% en su producto interno
bruto bruto y al menos 550 mil puestos
de empleos perdidos durante este el
próximo año pero atravesamos el
atlántico hablamos de la petrolera
mexicana pemex que registra utilidades
durante el primer trimestre de 2022 así
se desprende de un informe presentado a
la bolsa de valores mexicana en el que
revelan que obtuvo utilidades por 122
mil 493 millones de pesos casi 5 mil
millones de dólares en este periodo ello
es una buena noticia porque en el mismo
período pero del año anterior a esta
empresa había registrado pérdidas por
encima de los 1.800 millones de dólares
el informe refiere que el incremento en
las ventas y una ganancia cambiaria por
el fortalecimiento del peso frente al
dólar propiciaron el resultado tras
ingresos por el orden de los 25 mil
millones de dólares bueno vamos ahora
australia porque debido a la atención
comercial con china que afecta
principalmente a los vinos australianos
los productores de uva se están viendo
afectados es una decisión que viene como
consecuencia a la medida del gobierno
australiano de excluir a la empresa
china huawei de su red 5g de acuerdo con
la agencia de noticias ap las ventas de
vino australiano en china han caído en
los últimos años un 30 por ciento y por
supuesto a los productores de uva les
perjudica primero en el precio que ha
caído de 500 a 290 dólares y también en
la cosecha ya que no toda la producción
irá a las bodegas de vino australia ha
llevado el caso la organización mundial
del comercio pero mientras esperan una
resolución los productores buscan nuevos
mercados para colocar su producto louis
a usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica ya continuamos aquí
en directo américa con nuestro espacio
de corresponsales